i really like rey i think it's great to
see women of color in business but you
don't need to protect your skin against
blue light from screens even with a big
ass monitor you would need days or
months to get the same blue light as 15
minutes of sun and if you do want to
protect against blue light from the sun
which honestly isn't a big issue for
most people these products still
probably won't do much the active
ingredients are antioxidants which could
potentially mop up the free radicals
that the light causes in your skin but
that's so much less effective than
blocking the blue light from getting
into your skin in the first place like a
sunscreen for that you'd use foundations
or tinted sunscreens which have iron
oxides in them and you probably have
antioxidants in your skincare already
i'm sure the products are fine they're
reasonably priced they'll probably get
more people into looking after their
skin they probably could have included a
sunscreen but chill out on the screen